إنه جزء من الصلصة السرية في
بيج ماك الخاص بك ، والتوابل في روبن الخاص بك ،
إنه كريمي وحامض منعش وسمي على
اسم جزء خلاب من ولاية نيويورك
أتحدث عن ثاوزند آيلاند الذي يحتوي
على أصل تتبيل ثاوزند آيلاند الذي
يعود إلى أعلى
المراتب  من المجتمع الأمريكي ، كيف أصبح كل شيء
جيدًا ، حيث أصبحت الأشياء
مثيرة للاهتمام تكمن قصتان في
قلب نزاع ملابس ثاوزند آيلاند ،
هناك آلان فينوس المالك السابق لـ
Thousand Island Inn حيث يدعي أن
الملابس قد تم تقديمها لأول مرة للجمهور
ثم هناك جورج بولت ،
فندق EA الأسطوري الذي ابتكر
طاهيه الملابس وقدمها في فنادقه ، حيث
تعقبنا خبيرًا في جورج بولت
لشرح قصته ،
كان جورج بولت مهاجرًا روسيًا
ارتقى إلى أحد أبرز رجال الفنادق في الفندق.
الأمة كان يحب أيضًا
قضاء إجازة في الألف جزيرة يومًا ما
السيد.  كان
بولت وزوجته لويز يركبان على متن قارب
على أحد اليخوت الخاصة بهما
والطاهي أشعر بالملل لارتدائه ملابس متينة
لذلك ارتجل وابتكر ما
أصبح يُعرف باسم ملابس ثاوزند آيلاند
التي أحبها كثيرًا حتى بدأ في
تقديمها  عند جدار فندق أستوريا
في مدينة نيويورك ، لكن وفقًا
للرجل الآخر ألين فينوس ، لا شيء سوى
إشاعات أن الضمادة قد نشأت من
قبل زوجة مرشد صيد من كلايتون
يُدعى صوفيا مالون ، وقد أعطت الوصفة
للمالكين الأصليين للفندق
حيث  تم تقديمه لأول مرة في مكان تناول
الطعام بعد أن اشترينا الفندق
، وكان البحث في كل شيء
في الخزنة عبارة عن ورقة بها
وصفة ولم أكن متأكدًا مما
كانت قد أخرجتها إلى طاقم المطبخ لدينا
و  قال رئيس الطهاة إنها تبدو لي
كوصفة لتزيين الألف جزيرة ،
لذا هل سنتعلم الحقيقة أبدًا أنه
لا يوجد شيء أكثر شهرة من
الأساطير المتنافسة
أو أشهى
[موسيقى]